first and foremost congratulations on
this show steven it is
so great i was a huge fan of queers folk
growing up and i feel like it's a common
thread for us as queer people especially
of our age that i would watch this on
television and i wasn't out
nobody knew i was queer i'd be down
watching it i'd hear the footsteps and
i'd flip the channel and i feel like
that really is such a common thread for
us as queer people having a show like
this because there wasn't a lot on
television that represented the queer
community so tell me about your
experience growing up with queers folk
well i'm just going to echo exactly what
you said because i was down in my
basement which looked something like the
basement that you're in right now
um i had i had cedar behind me too um
but i um
i it was something i watched in secret
in private i was terrified because i saw
something of myself reflected in it and
that is such a powerful
thing because once you see it you can't
unsee that
um and so i just felt um
you know the power of that of the of
that that show really it resonated with
so many other people like me so it's
it's really such an honor to be able to
open this new chapter of the series
but to think about it when you were that
age to where you are now like when you
actually sit and think about what you
have accomplished does it give you a bit
of like oh my gosh i can't believe this
is my life
a little bit um i mean we just drove
past like the billboard for the show
today the first time it like went up and
i'm like
i can't believe that it's here you know
i can't believe we're doing this we've
been working on the show for a long time
let's be real this show it's been five
years in the making of this and you know
to be at this point where now it's being
released out into the world and like
when i think about that little kid in
newfoundland who
you know
didn't have anyone to talk to
couldn't watch this with anyone couldn't
tell anyone they were watching it
yeah it really um it's empowering to be
here today
i i believe it i i don't know you and i
am proud of you for making this come to
to the world because i feel like it is
going to
just be so powerful for people because
listen the other
versions of queer spoke we all know were
very white um and very one thing and to
now in 2022 have a version of queer
spoke that is reflective of the real
queer community that is out there there
are kids out there who are going to sit
down
and maybe do the same thing that we did
as children and put this on and flip the
channel but they won't feel as alone and
that really is incredible
absolutely and my hope is actually that
now we're in a time hopefully when maybe
we can leave that last channel button
out of the equation and that people can
actually not watch it with the volume
turn down mute on mute but like maybe
turn it all the way up yeah like that is
my that is my hope but obviously not
everyone you know not everyone has that
that luxury but that is the hope is that
you know we're we have
i think a very you know it was very
important for me for the show to be
inclusive to um not overlook obviously
we can't represent it we have eight
episodes
we cannot represent every single person
that's not gonna happen not in its first
season at least
um but you know it was very important
for me to make sure that we use this
title to make sure that other members of
our community feel welcomed and included
in this new iteration chapter of the
show
i just spoke to johnny and devin who are
so incredible in this show like they are
so perfectly casted how did you know
when you found your brody
actually i think we did a chemistry read
with uh with noah
with um johnny and devon together and it
really clicked at that point um but it
was um you know we searched far and wide
all over the world for these
for this incredible cast
and um yeah devin just stormed through
the door and he was so charming and so
winning and so vulnerable
um and just really brought that
character to life in a way that honestly
i actually didn't really fully expect he
brought something new something very
um unique to him
yeah definitely incredible in that role
the series has so much queer joy and
that is something i love about it
because i often find that a lot of queer
series and films deals with a lot of
trauma and leaves out the joy part and
this obviously deals with a
pulse like club shooting at babylon and
um you know i think that's really
important for queer people to
see that
we are resilient but i think it's also
just so important to remind people that
being queer is also fun it's not all
trauma was that very important in your
mind when creating the show to include
both
i absolutely went absolutely when i was
developing the show
at that time like there was no way i
could reimagine queers folk without this
element of the show not because we
needed another tragedy storyline but
because of what happened following um
the the
following pulse
you know it was it was the first time i
felt like i'd seen the community come
together
in a way you know we're big we're big
diverse sprawling community and we don't
always get along
um but um but after pulse it it was it
was uh you know obviously a very
traumatic event for those who
experienced it and it had a ripple
effect around the entire world but there
was an outpouring of love of joy of
resilience that came out of that and
that is the story that we're telling in
our show we never show the shooting we
never show
um the shooter we've seen that story
we've heard about that story that's not
what we're giving energy to here
what we want what we wanted to do is
tell them a story of empowerment of how
to how to rebuild
um a space
um and make it bigger better and more
inclusive than maybe the space that
existed before it and i think that's
what we
you know that's the message i hope to
get across with the show you did get
that message across and before we go i
know that you were friends with somebody
who
i absolutely adored um
chichi and i were friends on instagram
and we would message each other and when
people ask me i work in drag a lot i
host the drag series here in canada um
and whenever anybody yells
uh it's for out tv so it's uh
yeah it is cool um but whenever anybody
asks me because that's a question they
always ask me is who's your favorite
drag artist
and for me
it's always been chichi because there
was something there's just something
that is
so powerful in the way
that chi chi
held herself
and spoke to people and her drag was
incredible um but i know that you were
very close with chichi and chichi was
potentially going to be in this series
um
obviously
chichi sadly passed away and it was a
shock for everybody um but what was
your favorite thing about chi-chi
oh my gosh wow um that's a great
question you know i
i really
you know what i think my favorite thing
was um
it was realizing how important chichi
was to her like to zavian yeah
you're gonna make me cry
so i'm too early for this but
like
i don't think what i think people didn't
really know about chichi is that
that character gave her so much
strength to get through
a lot in her life yeah and i think like
i think that's what i took
what i took from her is like the
importance of like
living authentically and how how
how crucial it is to do that now
you know and to not wait no not waste
any more time
yeah
well listen i'm sorry to bring the mood
down but i felt like i couldn't talk to
you because i am such a fan of chi chi
and like i said we would dm and chichi
was always um
just the best and i always wanted to
have the chance you know we were trying
to connect and do interviews and of
course things happen but
um you know i'm just i'm grateful that
we all had chichi in our lives in one
way or another and i think i'm so
grateful too and she is always going to
live on in our show i don't know if you
caught any references but we've named a
couple of locations after her the main
intersection
of um of our show the venue ghost [ __ ]
the the restaurant across the street is
called chichi's diner
and the grocery store that is noah's
house or what
used to be noah's house um is called the
vain's grocer and so forever chichi's
name is set in stone at the precipice of
the main location of our show i love
that so much stephen congratulations on
this series it is fantastic you should
be so proud the entire cast should and
uh can't wait for season two thank you
so great chatting with you thank you so
much we'll talk soon
you